con la ayuda de un amigo español
de visual politique este video
va a explicar la
crisis del gobierno español y las elecciones el país de
España está en crisis no solo económica
sino también su democracia su sistema de
gobierno está paralizado la mayoría de la gente
es consciente de que el 2008  La crisis global fue
devastadora para la economía española en el primer
trimestre de 2013 hubo una
tasa de desempleo de veintiséis punto
nueve cuatro por ciento para la perspectiva durante
la Gran Depresión en América el pico
de desempleo fue del 25 por ciento
particularmente afectados son los trabajadores jóvenes
cuya tasa de desempleo se sienta  en
alrededor del 45% esto a pesar de que
la generación actual de jóvenes
españoles es la generación más educada
en la historia de España
esto significa que más jóvenes españoles están
dejando el país en busca de trabajo
y muchos de los que se quedan están
desempleados o subempleados la
política española  El sistema es aún joven su
Constitución recién fue ratificada en 1978
después de la muerte de  Si el dictador
Francisco Franco España es una
monarquía constitucional con una
legislatura bicameral conocida como cortes
generales, el rey actúa principalmente como
figura decorativa como en el Reino Unido.
que funciona como
un parlamento elegido de manera proporcional
a través de elecciones generales en cada una
de las 50 provincias de España como la mayoría de las
democracias no es un sistema impecable
el presidente que actúa más como un primer
ministro se conoce como presidente de
gobierno y es elegido por un
voto mayoritario en el Congreso de los diputados el
actual primer ministro de españa mariano
rajoy
del partido popular de españa apenas se
aferra al poder sus años en el cargo
desde que fue elegido en 2011 han sido un
caos de rescates corrupción e
indicadores económicos estancados así que profundicemos
con este tema para explicar cuán
locas se pusieron las cosas bajo ahoy, aquí está uno
de los anfitriones de visual politique
Fon  seca él y su equipo publican videos
sobre política española y eventos mundiales
todas las semanas, así que si hablas
español definitivamente deberías suscribirte
en España todos recordamos lo que sucedió
durante el fin de semana donde la
economía española estuvo al borde del colapso el
presidente y los
ministros estaban  reunidos en Bruselas para
una reunión con los funcionarios europeos que
intentan evitar un rescate del
Banco Central Europeo el mismo día que nuestro
Rey se rompió la pierna mientras cazaba
elefantes en un safari escoltado por una
rubia absolutamente desconocida y caliente
al mismo tiempo que el  La ministra de Trabajo estaba
jugando a candy crush mientras celebraba la
reunión y nos enteramos porque
tuiteó desde su cuenta oficial
que acababa de anotar 10.000 puntos y además
tenemos una corrupción desenfrenada que va desde la
monarquía a todos los partidos políticos,
incluido el Partido Popular Español, también conocido como
partido.  popular existe esa
sensación general de impunidad cuando vemos que
periodistas famosos son despedidos de su
n  los periódicos cuando están empezando a
investigar a un político corrupto
encima tenemos Cataluña
Cataluña, la segunda región más rica
de España, está organizando un referéndum
de autodeterminación a
diferencia del Reino Unido, la Constitución española
no contempla tal asunto y
la presidenta marina La  Jolla ha
rechazado varias veces reunirse con los
políticos catalanes, no olvide que
la integridad nacional es uno de los
pilares fundamentales de la plataforma conservadora española
, pero otra de ellas es cómo llegó al
poder bajo la promesa de impuestos bajos
y políticas favorables a las empresas, sin embargo, en
solo una semana.  después de que asumió su
primer anuncio fue el
aumento fiscal más grande en la historia de toda
nuestra democracia desde entonces no hay impuesto
que no haya sido incrementado dramáticamente
incluyendo la creación de nuevos
tributos especiales a industrias como la energía verde
por ejemplo es por eso que a pesar de tener un
administración conservadora España ha
descendido en todos los rankings en materia de
eco  la libertad económica o la facilidad para hacer
negocios
olivewood fonseca dijo que condujo a una
situación salvaje para las elecciones generales de 2015
la gente estaba harta de los dos grandes
partidos que habían gobernado desde los
primeros días de la democracia española en los
años 80 había dos nuevos
partidos independientes que  compitieron por el control del
congreso español de dépôt Davos, los
anti-austeridad podemos
unidos podemos y los ciudadanos centristas que
significan ciudadanos
curiosamente a diferencia de los
insurgentes populistas de derecha de usted Kip en el frente Nacional del Reino Unido
en Francia Golden Dawn y el
engrasador AFD en Alemania
grande  El nuevo movimiento político de España
realmente venía del centro y la
izquierda, así que quiénes eran las personas detrás de
Ciudadanos y Podemos Aquí está Fonseca
Eva vanna Surgieron hace diez años como una
plataforma política de izquierda
contra el nacionalismo catalán Ahora
se han convertido en liberales a nivel nacional
Partido cuando se trata de temas sociales
, tienen una especie de posición de izquierda
pero abrazan la libertad.
-mercado y bajos impuestos podemos, por otro lado,
fue fundada en 2014 por ex miembros del
Partido Comunista Español, son
un líder carismático SuperDuper públicamente
chiítas solía ser un cerebro político
para el ex presidente venezolano Hugo
Chávez con una agenda contra la austeridad y
la  La mejor campaña política que he
visto en toda mi vida,
bueno, deben haberse convertido de cero a
héroe en cuestión de meses y ahora
tienen serias posibilidades de asumir el cargo.
sombra de lo que solían ser y ninguno
de ellos obtuvo suficientes escaños como para formar un
gobierno por sí mismos después de que
se contaron las votaciones los resultados fueron
claramente históricos La Cámara PP obtuvo la mayoría de los
votos 28,7
% menos dieciséis coma tres por ciento desde
la última vez  fue significativamente menor
que en 2011 PSOE los socialistas perdieron
representación también con un 22 por ciento un
descenso del 6,8% desde las últimas
elecciones los verdaderos ganadores fueron los
Los partidos insurgentes Podemos y Ciudadanos
habían ganado el 20,7%
y el 13,9% respectivamente, claramente ningún
partido tendría la mayoría en el
Congreso de los diputados, lo que significaba que
dos o más de los partidos tendrían que
formar una coalición para elegir un
primer ministro.
Comenzaron difíciles negociaciones para formar gobierno
básicamente solo había dos posibles
coaliciones,
la primera sería un matrimonio
entre la población y los socialistas de Estados
Unidos, pero España está demasiado polarizada
como para juntar a socialistas y
conservadores, la otra alternativa
sería una izquierda.  gobierno con
podemos y socialistas juntos
apoyado por todos los partidos regionalistas
incluyendo la lista independentista catalana
no obstante las condiciones puestas por
podemos
vistas como draconianas por los socialistas la
intransigencia de los partidos hizo
que el congreso
no pudiera formar gobierno  y se
disolvió por completo el 3 de mayo
se celebrarían nuevas elecciones i  n junio de 2016
esta es una crisis existencial para España
después de la dictadura más larga en la
historia de Europa bajo Francisco Franco
el regreso del rey y el regreso de
una democracia representativa fue un
movimiento positivo para este hermoso país
. Viví en España por última vez.  dos años
y creo firmemente que la gente de
allí merece algo mejor que la corrupción
y el estancamiento al que han sido
sometidos para seguir las elecciones en
España y recibir otras noticias mundiales,
asegúrese de suscribirse a visual
politique.  algunos de sus mejores videos en
la descripción y en los comentarios si
quieres aprender más sobre la
política española y europea o simplemente
quieres mejorar tu español no
olvides visitar nuestro canal
publicamos un nuevo video todos los lunes
y el jueves, espero
verlos detenerse ahora, si desean
escucharme explicar las primarias estadounidenses en
español con un acento realmente triste, sigan
adelante y hagan clic en este video aquí para  watch
over on visual politic later
guys por ejemplo see Donald Trump consiga el
fin cuenta por ciento de los votos de
Tejas inti Oriya tendrá en cuenta dela
God owes que votaron por el en la
convención Nacional Republican